can you hear me now yes okay good and
actually there is a laptop down here I
was told there would be somebody here to
turn it on for me don't see anybody here
let me see if I can
you're right this is a problem i have
you usually Lenore comes to these talks
with me and she's my backup help who
knows okay well maybe somebody will come
in that's all right net right yeah yeah
well we'll manage I think this is in the
right place but I'm not sure it doesn't
matter it came it came it's okay this is
life will have no idea no that's that's
Don canoes or download that's coming
there okay well that's all right that
human computation I think I'll be okay
thank you very much I don't know oh oh
yeah yeah that's right no click click on
what no I don't want that
okay actually maybe like okay good that
was a very good suggestion close close
it yeah so this this is a talk on human
computation basically what I've been
interested in is is trying to apply some
of the theory that we do in computer
science so what it is that we humans do
or sometimes must do in our head but
first I'd like to start with some
personal observations and thoughts on
you dick so it's hard to roast dick for
one thing I really liked the guy for
another he is so enormously competent he
knows a lot he reads a lot he has and
maintains connections to everyone he has
impeccable taste his incredible
contributions to the cook car plevin
theory of np-completeness will in my
opinion long stand the test of time and
his you know his work in it that came
out of his knowledge of a great many
interesting different practical problems
like click and traveling salesman
problem and graph coloring and so on you
know cook came out with NP completeness
then had an example of click and then
carp said oh click that's important and
that was great all the wonderful stuff
that came out of that after there so
indeed when his work on the 21 NP
complete problems came out he pointed
out that there was a conference at the
time having talks on about that many
papers all of which were NP complete
it's great so unless you have to
dick is heavily biased to theoretical
computer science and actually not much
interested in fact disinterested in
stuff like botany so did you know that
have you seen the this this movie the
Martian were Matt Damon at some point
quips that he's the best botanist on the
planet okay good anyway it's one point
when I suggested that two-year-old
Jeremy was showing was showing what
appeared to me to be a definite interest
in botany he replied I hope not that's
okay it's okay okay which reminds me I
must surely have made dick cringe though
he didn't show it though it was a
terribly good sport about it when I gave
Jeremy his first driving lesson at age
two did you know that a confident
two-year-old can learn to drive a car he
can't reach the accelerator or the
brakes I did that for him but he can
steer when he saw the car going a wee
bit to the left he turned the steering
wheel all the way to the right and he
then saw it going to the right he turned
it all the way to the left and the car
careened down the street in a zigzag
kind of a way it was fun to be at
Berkeley with dick for one he taught
hugely informative courses I learned
a lot from him often indirectly through
the students taking his courses that's
how I learned that a coupon collector
must buy n log and boxes of cereal to
have a reasonable chance to get a full
set of n coupons remember you must have
been some time after that course you
asked me do you know how many and I said
n log n you didn't know that faith Vic
had just told me anyway you were pleased
that I knew something here ok I also
learned specific wonderful applications
of K wise independence from you dick in
this case through Steven rootage my
biggest heart ache at Berkeley was every
time it appeared that dick would leave
berkeley for stanford the possibility he
might do that really killed me at one
point i think around 1979 the head of IE
o our did this incredibly stupid thing
he demanded that dick who was one of
their best if not the best of their
teachers teach some low-level course
that dick had no interest in none it was
kind of like when eecs asked me to teach
fortran
but eecs didn't press me on it I eor did
press dick so I used the opportunity to
persuade dick to come a hundred percent
into CS I told him he could teach
whatever he wanted and however much or
little he wanted maybe I wasn't entitled
to do that but i did and besides I knew
you were acting honey my greatest joy
was to see him take me up on it and go
one hundred percent into CS and he did
teach a lot and well the appropriate
courses dick was founding chairman for
computer science he was eloquent he made
us computer science faculty so proud
when he spoke for us I am really
fortunate to count you a friend thank
you did you did my court my my talk
today is a sort of a let it's supposed
to be a lecture on human computation
which is something I've been working on
lately and I was going to talk about
captures these so i'll talk about
captures but i thought last night oj
this is a this is an opportunity for me
to give dick actually dick and jeremy a
gift actually this will be a gift for
all of you so I've been working on
password creation schemas these are
algorithms that a human can do in their
head to transform websites the website
names viewed as challenges into
passwords which are the responses
you know of course that you're supposed
to have different passwords for
different websites you probably also
know that before you enter your password
you should make sure you're at the right
website lately banks are beginning to
realize this they show you a picture
that you've selected to make sure that
you realize you're at the right place
but of course of the picture weren't
there would you remember you probably
just type in your password that would
give away something so with my password
schemas there is no problem like that
you need to know the website name in
order to produce the password so the
schema transforms the website name like
Amazon or Google or ebay or amex it
transforms that into the password so so
they so I would yes okay so so I'm going
to give you some examples right this is
where I'll open up this laptop now what
should be something oh yeah Preston
probably return no okay no there
something okay good now let's see if I
can go up to where's the can you put a
yes
I've got only two overheads it is one of
them so let me just mention this because
I want to give this gift to dick and
Jeremy and then later to you and so I'm
going to do this by telling you that in
the summer Stephen rootage has this
program at Carnegie Mellon called Andrew
sleep Andrews Andrew Carnegie Andrew
sleep has a lot of bright high school
students and it's a lot of fun for me to
give my talk basically the first time I
went to give this talk I what I did was
I asked them for challenges you know if
you go to braincom or train net these
are possible website names anyway I
asked them to give me challenges and
then I transform their challenges which
are words like John Mary whatever you
want I wouldn't take amex or Amazon but
other words I would take and show them
that I could transform them into
passwords have a Python program I know
despite my ineptitude here I actually
can write Python program to to actually
do this and I would have one student
check me that I was doing the right
transformation because actually I make
mistakes and and and that was good but
fortunately and then I would have them
as I said suggest challenges at one
point oh by the way they of course they
would see that I could transform a
challenge into a password and never more
than 25 seconds the students who who I
asked the time made time in said 18
seconds but anyway it can be done
quickly here you see oh yeah so here you
you see a brain train grain and drain
which one of those high school students
came up with I love it high school
students it's their job it's like an IQ
test actually this is a great IQ test
for you too it's like an IQ test I had
told them how the thing works but they
still have to from that be able to get
more details they have to be able to see
what's going on here brain train brain
drain you see the the intent is to try
to see what might be going on and do you
see anything going on their brain train
brain drain oh yeah that's because I
didn't the program actually generates 10
letters but i only put five up okay so
let's see now how do i go to the next
one okay so here's another one somebody
what happened there magic one magic to
there seems to be a magic missing but
anyway somebody had asked me how I go
about changing my passwords when I go
from one year to the next and so I said
give me a challenge they said magic and
then I produced the response to magic
one magic to magic three and so on and
again I can ask you do you see what's
going on there so I'm going to leave
this up for now because this is an IQ
test for you to try to see what's going
on and in what I'm going to do is I'm
going to ask jeremy and dick to come up
and and i'm going to tell them how to do
something like this the you'll notice
there are two boards here separated in
such a way that one put no stay here
because that's explain it to you see I'm
going to first whisper in your ear how
to do this and while they're trying to
figure out what's going on there Oh
whisper and
and write some things here oh yeah your
mic thank you very much this could have
been a disaster here okay so let's see
so don't forget you're supposed to
figure out what's going on there by the
way did you see what's going on there
you see anything that's going on what
the last number in the magic really
you'll notice that there's also one two
three four zero which is completely you
know at magic for goes to 1 2 3 4 0
that's completely has nothing no no
reason for pure coincidence ok so now
you have to come up with a challenge to
give these people please don't make it a
huge challenge I mean American Express
is kind of getting there yeah you know
make it a four-letter challenge what kar
p that's good because you're supposed to
be able to spell it and I think these
two people do know how to spell it so
yes write it down and see now we're
going to see so they have not heard this
before they don't know what this is go
ahead use also for Pepe and then 35 k
no for three to four you could just
change this
he did this this happens when when I do
this to I I often put in my passwords
more than once so are they the same hey
good that worked you want to do another
one no no no that's not that's not
interesting something you have a guest
room thats ok so done would you care to
give a challenge is they have to know
now make it three or four you're not
supposed to produce make it a four
letter word a nice one they have to be
able to spell it co NP good that's a
good way to say it yes
yeah I think generally wanders no no
this is fantastic I have done this with
other people you're a very good dick I
mean usually passed 70s there much
slower thank you and you got the same
thing he got ya so must be right Thank
You Jeremy thank you carp dot edu carp
that oh can I invert yeah they can
invert
yeah of course I told them how to do it
I can invert you you want me to invert
it which I need to the pen okay well
I'll just do it up here
you believe me you believe me I mean I
don't have Jeremy over there doing it
too okay
it's not secure I'll tell you what will
be secure
that's supposed to be an end so did this
crossing did you choose that I'll tell
you the general method which is pretty
secure I only it's based on the
telephone number you have to know a
telephone number preferably not the
telephone number you currently use but
you know some telephone number you
remember from when you were a kid nobody
used that telephone number okay then so
here's what you do you you use that you
take the first digit of that telephone
number what I gave them was that they
had to remember the telephone number 4 3
2 4 3 2 dash for three to four they did
remember that that's good so and then
what they were told to do is you see the
a look at the coat and pee you see the P
start with the last letter go for past
it go for past the p q r s t that gives
you the team then go to the see that's
above what you just wrote go three past
it because c d e f there's the f then go
to the now you've done the f you see the
O go to past it o P Q here's the keels
and then there's the end above it go for
past it because that's the next digit
for pat n is 0 P Q R this is not very
secure what you the actual thing that I
suggest you do is you create a sentence
for yourself which has all the letters
of the alphabet you know some sentences
like that the quick brown fox jumps over
the lazy dog don't use that don't use it
you make up your own sentence or makeup
take a few words that have most of the
letters that will do and then what you
do is you go for past that are that's
how we got a four pass to the P took you
two are but you don't you use are what
you do is you look in the sentence the
quick brown you see the are and brown
the quick brown fox you use the oh that
comes st and then you go on to see well
see you use a telephone number to get
the tea and then the quick the it has a
tea in it it becomes H and so on then
you f the quick brown fox there's a no
and then q well what comes out to q use
so that would be the string you produce
you use your telephone number and then
the string and if you get reasonably
good at it it takes you no more than 20
to 30 seconds to do it okay
what yeah oh yeah yeah that's a very
good point so i have to tell you a
secret about my passwords that you would
get as soon as you saw any one of them
all my passwords start with a lowercase
a and uppercase a and at sign and at one
the let me just mention because that's
very good Mike that the rules that the
the you know these non theoreticians
they don't they make up these rules
which are so easy to circumvent there's
just not in fact I have one of the first
things you do as a theoretician when you
look at the password problem as you
realize that it's a problem with
transforming challenges to responses
I've never seen that in the literature
never does anybody here seeing that
mentioned yes it's a different schema it
turns out that since that's an old
scheme it's the one I use it's not as
good because when you've generate digits
it's really not as good as generating
letters in fact you know these these
password checkers you know you make a
passwords you're supposed to try them
out on password checkers actually that's
a bad idea you're going to tell Google
your passwords anyway these password
checkers are just terrible the just
really put like like this business of
use strange letters and okay so so that
you want to here's the password checker
i use i have done no have no idea how
good this is but first of all i have the
schema i will never actually use a
password checker on an actual password
you
use it on four challenges that I'm non
they're interested in take the password
you get from a challenge that you're not
really interested in and see if Google
recognizes the word that's produced now
that's a nice password checker if Google
recognizes the word it's not a good
password or it could be good but it's
not as good as when Google gives up its
turn you know says ouch I don't see it I
have nothing in I have nothing that
looks like that you have to watch out
because you put in a string of letters
and it will often suggest Scrabble yeah
well I don't rely on that I just use
challenge I you I use I test the schema
I don't test the actual password I now
know that for for this for example you
really want to have challenges or seven
or eight letters long but four digits
you they have to be much longer these
these are only I've only given you half
the the password there the the the
passwords I produce are actually twice
that length yes
the changing one yes it's bad in that
respect it's bad the one up up there
doesn't have that property but the one
up there takes a bit of time to and it
only produces digits much better would
be something work so but nevertheless it
doesn't matter the security the proof of
security is based on the fact it's based
on how many challenge responses you have
to see in order to produce in order to
enable the adversary to who knows the
schema to be able to figure out what
you're doing so basically the proof just
depends on the fact that there's some
that cohen p has a some letter that you
didn't didn't appear in carp so it you'd
be hard-pressed to tell what it was the
proofs in this human computation are all
just there are not compete they are not
they don't make use of their just
information theoretic the proofs are of
the form if you haven't seen enough of
the information then you simply can't
information theoretic cruise the fact is
that humans can't do very much
computation in their head and almost
anything that I can ask a human to do if
you know what the schema is you can
actually you can you can you can easily
write a program to break it you know
like I've seen kids multiply there's a
kid who can multiply 25 digit numbers in
his head in three minutes it's pretty
amazing he doesn't using his hands in
funny ways you can do but how long would
it take to factor the number doesn't
take any any time at all so the point is
that the usual security that we expect
that doesn't come up
haha nice okay you have to memorize a
poem and and then it's like a one-way
pad once you're done with that poem you
don't hopefully don't use it and fact
hopefully it's not a very well-known
poem where it's homey made up yourself
yeah so yes um let's see well let's see
yes oh I could just mention another
thing about the schema that that's fun
for me first of all let me just tell you
that these are pretty secure people
worry about in this group everybody
worries about security when the real
question is is it humanly usable can you
actually as a human being do it and as
long as every every challenge is
producing a different password there's
no problem so here's here's something
that have experience with because about
once a month Lenore comes to me and says
man well what's your password for such
and such a sight the last time she
wanted to know REI what's your password
for rei so I could honestly tell her
look I don't know if I even have if I'm
even registered at rei but if I am
here's my password and re is threes are
produced six digits but and i started
with lowercase a uppercase a at sign in
the one right
and it's amazing as in the case of rei
she calls down and says hey yeah you're
registered air conditioning just came on
let's see when did this this talk was
supposed to start at three I'm way past
right I was going to talk to you about
captures but where that came about but i
think i'm at a time here so let me these
are very kind people here they haven't
put up notices that i'm way at a time
okay so I'm I'll just end it right there
thank you very much